a couple years ago there was this thing
going around where people were looking
at the posts that you were liking on
Instagram and who you were who you
follow and there was a lot of people
jumping to conclusions a lot of posts
and videos even videos made about about
animals well Me by secondary but use
like because Andrew follows these people
on Instagram that means that Ellen is a
this is this I think it's silly when
people would make such big assumptions
based off following someone on Twitter
or Instagram or Facebook or whatever it
is I like having disagreements with
people like I don't mind having
political discourse or having different
opinions on things that doesn't trigger
me or some people for whatever reason
it's more like how could someone think
something else than me like they must be
this type of person and that's just not
me so it's easy for me to follow
different people on social media that I
agree with and disagree with it's not
triggering for me to see someone post
something that I disagree with I'm like
oh that's interesting it's not like it
ruins my day to see someone even if I
think it's like something that could be
possibly harmful I understand that
people come from all different ways of
life and have so many different
upbringings that we kind of form our
opinions about things politically or
just what our priorities are in life
based off a lot of what we know our
childhood and things that may or may not
have happened to us or our parents or
the religion we grew up in and to
understand that people get to a certain
point because of the experiences they
have it helps you understand them a
little bit better and when you put
people in boxes and just say oh this
person voted for this person or follows
this person it kind of takes away their
humanity and it's not going to be very
fruitful for our country here for people
in general that we just treat people
like that
that was my husband lover father of our
five children and best friend Andrew
he's one of those people that may seem
like a man of few words but when you get
him talking about something he's
passionate about and give him the floor
he shines today you'll get a sneak peek
into our intimate conversations how we
speak to one another what we laugh about
and take seriously and the vulnerable
about the good and the bad are fights
how we work out disagreements and keep
the spark alive after 20 years of doing
life together this is really a super
special episode because Andrew does so
much behind the scenes for the family
and isn't one to love the spotlight so I
feel really grateful that he agreed to
come on my podcast that he supports me
so much on without him and his support I
wouldn't be able to do any of this in
this episode we get into many of the
burning questions people have about him
in our relationship how we function in
our day-to-day and taking care of
ourselves as a priority we spend time
breaking down what makes our
relationship Thrive and keeping the
spark alive having children and his
experience being the father of five home
births and we open up about some of our
personal beliefs that we've been
criticized for or put into boxes about
so I hope you enjoy our conversation
welcome to the Ellen Fisher podcast
if you haven't spoiled yourself yet with
anything from ostea girl it is time to
treat yourself and get something Divine
from their shop and if you don't know
what osia is they are a clean vegan
seaweed-based skin and body care line
that's climate neutral and ocean
positive verified Lucia has an
incredible line of cleansers serums body
oils and more that makes my skin feel so
youthful hydrated and clean my favorite
routine to take care of my skin includes
prepping my face with the osea cleanser
then their hyaluronic sea serum and
ocean Eyes age-defying eye serum this
hydrating serum addresses all signs of
aging around the eyes it Smooths the
look of fine lines and crow's feet and
reduces the look of dark circles and
puffiness the cooling rollerball
applicator awakens the eye area and is
loaded with seaweed hyaluronic acid and
peptides and after that I use osea's
Advanced protection cream all of which
have been game changers in upping my
skincare routine so much so that I can't
believe I used to go without these
products that makes my skin feel so dewy
and Youthful so I got a discount code
for you guys so you too can have the
skincare routine of your dreams just
click the link in my show notes and
enter the code Ellen ocean for 10 off
your order that's
e-l-l-e-n-o-c-e-a-n
all right my husband my one that I love
so much I finally have you on the
podcast thanks for being here yep you
finally got me on I know a lot of people
want to know more about you and you're
not really in my stuff that much and
there's kind of a reason for that like
you're just not one that like loves the
spotlight that much but if anyone gets a
chance to sit down with you and engage
in a meaningful conversation they're
lucky because it's always like oh
Andrew's speaking be quiet let's see
what he has to say well thank you yes we
are two very different people we there's
a reason that I don't have my own
podcast and my own YouTube channel and
that you have yours and uh I get to make
little appearances when I feel like it
yeah
yeah the other day I showed you a video
of mine that I was about to post on
YouTube and the first thing I said in
the video was taking care of myself is
one of the most important things I do
and you said your response was it is
like with this because you're so humble
like you're the idea of taking care of
myself
is one of those things that you would
think would should be lower on the list
on like a conscious level but then my
sister who's visiting us right now
that's why we're able to do this because
we have my sister and her husband Eric
watching the kids because that's one of
the reasons it's been hard to pin you
down because we have so many children
you have so many
um people that you take care of you know
me included but she said well but Andrew
you're you do take care of yourself that
is like one of the biggest priorities
that you have you go to the gym almost
every day probably six is it six days a
week
five close yeah sometimes sometimes six
you push yourself to that limit every
time because you know you feel so good
going to the gym you eat so well you eat
better than I do you're more intentional
with
um like every single meal being the
foods that you know make you feel best
I'm more likely to dabble in you know
different fun stuff here and there and
you're just like a very consistently
healthy person you make sleep a priority
all these things that Hannah was
pointing out like well taking care of
yourself is one of the number one things
you do because if you weren't taking
care of yourself how would you handle
all the demands that we have what do you
think about it well that's true I taking
care of yourself is a top priority I
just didn't like the wording of that's
my number one priority because yes it's
a definitely a priority of mine like if
I don't feel my best if I'm tired if I
uh don't feel good in any way I'm not as
good of a parent I'm not as good of a
husband so yes going to the gym is my
favorite way to start the day because
when you work out you all those
endorphins and I just I feel way better
when I work out in the morning and I
feel like I'm a better person the rest
of the day but sometimes I don't
necessarily think about that when I'm
working out I just it's kind of become a
habit and I just feel like I need to do
it every day and then the days where I
don't do it I'm like my feeling
something's missing today
uh and then with the eating healthy I
mean
that's how I got started in the veganism
in the first place was starting to
dabble when you went vegan first and
then I started to share meals with you
and then I'd be like wait I feel better
when I eat this why would I not want to
do that all the time I wouldn't what why
wouldn't I want to feel my best all the
time yeah
um and that's the main reason why I tend
to want to eat healthy because when I
don't feel as good I don't feel like
getting off the couch I'm less likely to
say yes to the kids I'm more likely to
be grumpy same thing with being with
going to bed on time if I don't go to
bed on time then the next morning I'm
gonna feel lazy or I'm going to feel
more tired I'm not going to want to say
yes to the kids like I said I'm not
going to be as good of a spouse so I
guess it's just kind of subconscious a
lot of things I do are habits that I've
kind of formed over time
uh
so I just didn't really necessarily like
the way of phrasing it's my number one
priority because I don't want to think
of myself I don't try not to think of
myself as a selfish person we're all
selfish in certain ways I try to be
humble and I try to put others first but
you're right if you don't take care of
yourself then if that's not a top
priority then you're not going to be
very good at taking care of others yeah
so would you because I think the way I
find it was it's one of the most
important things I do but even just
saying it like that is a little bit
off-putting for you because it has this
selfish type of look like it's kind of
like the way that our culture is right
now like all about self-love me me me
whereas for you it's very like how can I
serve and take care of others like
you're just naturally really good at
that and that's something I've like
learned from you over time it's like you
know love languages so certain things
you just gravitate towards that you're
it could just come more naturally to you
and serving others is like your number
one thing that comes naturally to you so
it just sounds like a selfish thing but
when you break it down it actually is
one of the most important things one of
no yeah when you explained it like that
when Hannah explained it like that I I
agreed I just I just didn't like the way
it was worded but yes you should take
care of yourself it should be a top
priority yeah and I think people wonder
like how you are able to do all those
things like how you get to the gym and
do all the you know make making foods
from scratch and wholesome meals every
day a priority with how busy we are and
you're just one of those like you make
it work you you always can find a way to
make it work but do you have any like
suggestions for people who are like I
want to I just don't really have the
time well it depends on how big of a
priority it is for you if it's if it's
something that you're really passionate
about and you want to do then you gotta
change things in your life to to make
the time and for some people that's
easier than others for us it's we're
fortunate enough to be able to work from
home and always be around the house we
don't have to drive to work and commute
every day we don't have you know we're
not a slave to a job where we have to go
to every day so we set up our life that
way and then as a result we have more
time for these things but even when I
was working you know I still made uh
when I was working outside the house I
still made these things a priority it
was just I had to be more intentional
about it you know I had to set an alarm
and get up extra early or I had to skip
watching the show at night and go to bed
earlier so that I had the energy to wake
up earlier in the morning
I had to uh plan out my meals and maybe
prep them uh for dinner before I left
for something or before I went to work I
just had to be more intentional more
planned more each thing but it just
depends on how important something is to
you if eating healthy is important to
you
uh then make the time for it yeah well I
mean some people would even argue that
it takes even more intentionality now
because we do have five kids versus like
when we had one or two kids no you're
not but you're not like going off to
work like you know when we first moved
here 10 years ago now is it 10 yep 10
years ago next month yeah you were
working like 60 hours a week is that
what it was you'd gotten two different
jobs and maybe you can talk a little bit
about that yeah well the reason I was
able to make 60 hours a week work then
was I had
uh day job where I was the a tour guide
for zipline company for three two or
three days a week and so those days of
the week I had to work in the morning
and during the day but my other job uh
was a night job where I worked as a
manager at the grocery store nearby
and that was I would go in around four
o'clock and then I would come home
around midnight so I had time five six
or four or five days out of the week
where I could be at home with the family
I had plenty of time to exercise and and
spend time with you guys and I just
scheduled my jobs like that I know I
needed another job I I didn't find
another day job I found a job that I
could work at at night and then that
freed up my days to be able to get stuff
done and also I didn't have a job where
I was going to bed at you know six the
next morning I can go to bed at midnight
still get up at seven or eight in the
morning yeah and still spend time with
you guys and still be able to exercise
and stuff so I still had to schedule my
life and I remember having to change my
schedule around to get that schedule to
make it work and well that means you
talk to your boss or you find a new job
whatever it whatever it takes to
maximize to time with your kids and it
was nice having that job because a lot
of the hours I was working Elvis was
already or Elvis insane you were already
sleeping uh for you know good 20 30
hours of those work of the work week
which made it feel like less to the kids
and made it feel like less to me because
I still had a lot of time with them yeah
nowadays we don't go to bed at 12 though
like it's like 10 o'clock 10 30
sometimes 11 if it's like well when
Hannah's here yeah I know because then
we want to chat with Hannah and Eric and
then we're staying up too late or
anytime we have guests it's great having
this podcast having so many guests come
come through and getting to spend time
with them some guests have kept us up
later than others yeah it's always fun
it's so true because we're like let's
hang out again and we normally can get
the most quality conversations in after
the kids are asleep and then we really
could like break it down and if you know
Andrew and I at all we're just like very
into challenging discussions so we're
always like who wants to hang out with
us and chat with us after the kids go to
bed yeah I generally have more fun
connecting with other adults when the
kids are in bed just because the kids
take up so much of our time and so much
of our attention or we try to be more uh
more there for them and and and less
able to have those good deep
conversations with uh our friends or
people that are visiting or whatnot yeah
because you want to be present with them
and it's really hard to be present when
you're like getting into a really good
discussion about you know a variety of
different topics but your child you know
needs help you know I'm good on the
potty or changing a diaper or feeding
them and or just playing with them you
know and you want and you want to be
present with your kids I love being
present that I don't want I don't like
to feel distracted when our kids are
around you know and since we have so
many it takes even more intentionality
to be present and so that's when after
the kids go to bed that it's like we can
really engage well you're very good with
with being intentional with the kids in
your time with them thanks you try when
you're not working you're very very
intentional about being present for them
you're better than I am about putting
down the phone or putting down whatever
it is ah I'm more likely to be like I'm
watching my Dodger games
I know I made a joke I was like what if
one time because you know you know
Sports is like the X
where the
them too but to just turn it on in the
middle of the day for no good reason
other than just to watch it because the
excuse is like you can't record it and
watch it later so um but I thought about
if the rules were reversed like my
friends and I did y'all know stuff but
were like what if you played like a
prank on him where like he came home
from the gym and you're just like
chilling on the couch watching friends
or something and you'd be like what are
you doing we don't time for this why
aren't you doing this or that you know
cleaning the house or getting ready for
our next whatever Adventure but you have
that excuse because of sports yeah well
we live in Hawaii so the everything
starts way earlier we have football
starts at seven in the morning or six in
the morning on Saturdays uh so it
unfortunately Falls a lot of the times
when the kids are awake whereas if
you're on the East Coast or a West Coast
or somewhere else you know the games
come on at seven o'clock at night yeah
sometimes some of the later games so the
kids can go to bed you can stay up and
watch so oh yeah but it's fun time
bonding time with the boys and stuff
they like watching sports with me too
but yes it's yeah sometimes I get a
little sucked into my game so nobody's
totally created like a culture in our
house about sports and like I see Elvis
especially starting to act act like you
and you're in certain games and you know
Dodger baseball is like the number one
sport that we're gonna like all engage
in and love but going back to the phone
thing about putting the phone down like
you really are only on your phone when
you like for breakfast like for like
basically like it's the news for him and
we have this ongoing back and forth
conversation well is it going to be
received the same way as being on a
phone for looking at the news versus
like when our parents grew up and we're
looking at a newspaper in the morning I
don't know do you think it'll be
received the same way because maybe not
the younger kids younger kids don't know
what you do or you're doing like I think
of like uh when I read my Bible in the
morning like I generally do it on the
phone like the kids don't know what I'm
doing on my phone like am I reading the
news am I reading the Bible am I
scrolling through Instagram like yeah
they don't know unless they're older and
they come over and ask what I'm doing so
I don't think it's necessarily going to
be received the same way if I was just
sitting at my breakfast reading a book
I think it would definitely be received
a different way and we see that you know
you see that with kids they're like
always interested in our phone like what
is that like you look at it what is that
I'm interested what is that yeah Colfax
picking a number Scout so
it is something that I know we're both
working on to be intentional not to be
on it yeah around them as little as
possible yeah that's the Habit that I
like I really don't want the kids to
grow up feeling like
screen especially like a phone that you
have in your pocket everywhere you go
and like there's studies showing that
you know we don't want to be apart from
our phone farther than like 15 feet at
all times like you might go into another
room and you bring your phone like well
that is crazy to me how that culture
like we always need it by us in case
someone calls us or texts us or whatever
and so I try to just keep it on silent
all the time which Andrew doesn't love
because if he's out with the kids on
errands but needs to call me I don't
answer it like let's say he has two of
the kids with them and I have the other
three kids it's like you didn't answer
your phone and it's because I always
have it on silent but I think there's
like a setting you can change it to to
where like it only answers if you call
me you can do that I have the same
problem though I always have my phone on
silent and then people try to get a hold
of me and I'm about
ten percent of the time will answer a
phone call I didn't answer one today you
did yeah couldn't call me and I I
happened to walk by it and saw it the
screen it doesn't Buzz or anything but
yeah you just had yeah he got lucky
there's like a joke between of course
Danielle and Josef and I were always
looking at our text between our partners
and Danielle and her husband Jeremy they
are the most lovey-dovey sweetest in
real life but also in text with like you
look at their texts and they're sending
each other these like love notes in
between back and forth to each other all
throughout the day and they're like
longer messages it doesn't have to be
every day but it's just like when you
look at their conversations it's pretty
even but if you look at like
conversations with Andrew and text it's
like this long thing and then below is
like a okay or like thumbs up or got it
and then one time I had seen that you
were texting with one a friend of yours
and he's like super wordsy like I am and
I'm seeing you respond at the same way
I'm like you should probably give him
more words he would probably appreciate
that like a smile Emoji or something
yes I could work on my text game a
little bit but I'm not a man of many
words and text messaging is not my
favorite way to communicate but yes I
could be uh yeah I could probably say a
few more things than okay or just I like
the thumbs up button it's like got it
I'm like come on give me more than that
obviously if it's a question I'm going
to answer the question yeah but if it's
just a statement
I don't have a response to the statement
sometimes acknowledge that I that I saw
it and it's received
sure you agree that the health of you
and your loved ones and future loved
ones is a primary essential for all of
us in today's world our electronic
devices play a huge role in our lives
but all of our personal electronic
devices our laptops cell phones and
tablets emit radiation and electronic
radiation is linked to adverse health
effects enter safe sleep their mission
is to bring EMF radiation education and
protection to the masses safesleep
offers anti-radiation products designed
to give you the Peace of Mind of knowing
you and your devices are protected while
making them even easier to use all of
their anti-radiation products
incorporate lab tested shielding
technology that can block over 99 of RF
and 92 percent of Elf radiation and all
their cell phone cases provide military
grade drop protection which are also
tested by a third party evaluator both
my husband and I got a safe sleeve for
our iPhones and I love the beige color
that I chose it works as a stand and it
even has slots for your bank cards and
cash for an easy out and about
experience to get your own safe sleep
case for your cell phone tablet or
laptop just click my link below in the
show notes and enter the code ln10 for
10 off your order
but you actually are wordsy when it
comes to a topic that you get excited
about if someone just sits with you and
have a conversation like you have a lot
to say but you're slow to speak and
that's like something so admirable about
you that you're gonna wait until people
want to hear from you you're not going
to dominate a conversation which is
something that some people can depending
on your personality can have that like
get towards that habit yeah but it's
always admirable to see how like you
kind of wait until called on
if someone's interested yeah that's I
just think that's my my personality I
mean I just what I naturally gravitate
towards I mean as a child I was so quiet
and shy uh
I just remember like barely even being
able to talk to adults really I really
only was able to like open up around
people that I knew really really well or
obviously my friend my friend group and
my family group but like anybody that
wasn't like my age I had a really hard
time and I was really shy for a really
really long time I don't really know why
I just part of my personality I guess so
I feel like some of that is carried over
to adulthood yeah obviously I'm not that
same little boy but uh something I
definitely have to be worked on like we
talk joke about like when I'm in a
conversation with someone that I'm
meeting for the first time and they're
quieter than I am and I'm like oh man
that was really hard I had to ask him so
many questions
whereas for some people that's what
happens so naturally like there's some
people are just so good at asking
questions and then they just give the
other person the floor and for you it's
like a balance where you thrive well
with somebody who does talk a lot so
then but then ask you questions well
it's not it's more of what I asked a
question and then I get like a super
short response and it's like okay I
thought that was going to go longer than
that and then having to re-ask another
question getting a super short response
yeah that was that's more what I'm
talking about so whenever I do meet
someone like that it's like oh man that
was really hot that was like a lot of
work because I'm more introverted too or
it takes a little bit more out of me to
engage in conversations and stuff but
that's one of the reasons I married you
yeah that's how that's kind of how one
of the reasons we were attracted to each
other is the Opposites Attract thing I
was much more outgoing I don't know if
we ever would have got I mean most of
you listening or a lot of you listening
probably know that we started dating
when we were 15 we went to Junior High
and high school together first day I saw
him in junior high his he was like a
foot taller than anybody else like in
the crowd like who's that guy he's tall
that was like the first thing I thought
of at 13 years old and then we we
started to connect at 15 but we didn't
actually talk in public at school for
like months wasn't it months it was only
on AOL Instant Message yeah for how good
I was on AOL instant message it didn't
carry over to text messaging very well I
don't know maybe because it's like AOL
you had to be like signed in so it was
like you couldn't just like respond and
then wait for them to respawn like it
was like an immediate response normally
you're typing back and forth but yes
yeah I didn't that didn't carry over
well but yeah I was still shy back then
yeah oh that yeah and that's one of the
reasons why actually why we clicked
because like you were really interested
in me and you wanted to talk to me and
we just I don't know we just vibed
amazingly from the beginning and then
when we finally started chatting in real
life like I think that was like probably
after we were like official or close
close to being official Leroy was that
right so long ago
probably something like that yeah like
that yeah but okay so I asked my
last much for you and people put in so
many good questions because I'm like
what exactly should we talk about
specifically so I wrote a list of these
questions down because you're like we
said earlier kind of like the silent
partner and you come and make an
appearance when you want to and so I
think you're a little bit mysterious to
people like what do you really like and
what are your thoughts on things so I
have a whole list of really good
questions people asked I'm just gonna
get good we don't spend a lot of time a
lot of them but you ready sure I can see
some of them there so the first one was
what's it like being married to me
well
what's it like being married to your
best friend well you're my best friend
so it's pretty awesome
um
I mean
it's just all I know I mean I've been
with you for since I was I was 16. I'm
36 now
I just don't I don't know any other way
and it's awesome and uh
and I get to wake up next to you every
day and I'm happy and we get along well
99 of the time and
uh I'm attracted to you physically and I
love to connect emotionally and we love
to watch shows together we just share a
lot of the same interests
um what's it like to be married to you
like work Ellen like you're a very
dedicated person and you were very you
polite to plan everything and you always
get on me for planning everything but
you're a very big planner when it comes
to your work yeah and sometimes it's a
little
a little tedious you know feel like
you're a little too too plenty let's
just let's just see what happens kind of
kind of thing but you are so dedicated
to your work and uh getting to watch you
uh you know plan out your week can be a
little exhausting sometimes yeah just
just how perfectionistic I am on this
like you're like I could do that faster
that's what makes you successful and
what's made you the person you are and
what I love about you too but uh just
like a day to day like it's we don't
have too many days where we just sit
around being married to you like if I'm
like tempted to like I don't really feel
like doing much today I'm like oh I'm
gonna never let that fly it's like wait
what are you doing
yeah that's definitely something I have
a little bit of a productivity Obsession
there's so much on my list and I I feel
the most at peace when I everything is
checked off but nothing is ever going to
be checked no well I think we're both
kind of like that like we're not the
type of people to leave the dishes in
the sink overnight no like we're not the
type people to leave a gigantic mess in
the house and then go to bed it's like
all right I can't relax until we check
it out so we're both very similar yeah
in that way and it's nice being married
to someone that's like that yeah true uh
because we're on the same page yeah
being on the same page in most things
and I do like to plan things too I just
don't necessarily plan
that down to the yes every little detail
so that can be a challenge for me
sometimes be like oh come on we'll just
we'll see what happens kind of okay but
you are very like you are more detailed
in time than I am yes like you're like
we have to leave by 8 22. like that 8 20
8 20. five minute Windows yeah there's
like five minute windows I know I'm
making a joke but like pretty pretty
strict on the time and I'm much more
like okay we don't believe exactly at
this time like if we're at the beach
hanging out and I'm having a great time
and I'm like I don't I don't want to
leave and you're like we have to leave
exactly right now within five minutes or
else kovac's nap will be too late it's
all very logical like you're all you're
right like if we if we wait too long
then like kovac's nap will be too late
and then he won't want to go to bed on
time and then and then dinner will be
started really late and they're all
gonna be rushed for bed and you're right
but I'm like I'm having a great time I
don't want to leave so I feel like
you're more perfectionistic in certain
areas oh yeah yeah we both are what
we're just yeah and I feel like that's
we we understand each other enough and
that where it doesn't bother us whereas
maybe if you if you were married to
someone that wasn't
uh perfectionist is in a certain way it
would be that person may have a really
hard time with the type of schedule you
like to run or the type of time schedule
that I like to run yeah but if it wasn't
for me you would be late everywhere
maybe like 10 minutes late I'm not I'm
not a I'm not an unfashionable person
I'm a reliable person but I'm like 10
minutes but there's certain things you
can't relate to yeah like the dentist
but you got to be up there on time yeah
what are you doing I'm like stop leave
it alone I'll be there but I definitely
appreciate though The Importance of
Being at least mostly on time like if
you're if you're super late to something
it's pretty what's the word
rude yeah rude and unreliable like
because someone is waiting for you that
aspect so I I really rarely am more than
like five or ten minutes late you're
right yeah you're not you're not the
type of person to show up an hour late
late to something yeah or two hours
later
love you but come on
for sure but something that is
though is even though we're very similar
in the control and the like schedule
type person were very different in that
I like Aesthetics more and you like
comfort more everything that what any
type of house decision any type of any
decision that we're making is it
comfortable is it easier is it does it
does it is it practical and for me I'm
like is it beautiful is it aesthetically
nice I don't care if it takes this much
time longer I just want it to look
beautiful so that's kind of our ongoing
we model that every day with my chair
like folding the zero gravity chair that
I pull out of the closet and then
someone comes over and I have to hide it
in the room I'm like why can't I just
get a nice one here there is no nice
ones oh yeah there are any nice looking
glasses what about a good old-fashioned
recliner like hell no that's a no
no but then you know we give on certain
things so there's certain things that
like I would purchase but if they're not
comfortable or practical we don't we
don't get it you're like that's a no to
me so there's like we have a good
balance where we like care about each
other's feelings and we meet in the
middle
when it comes to furniture and around
the house we don't meet in the middle
you get your way yeah but
this is like I would like to do
landscaping but it's not very practical
because it's so much work to go and get
like pebbles and all that type of stuff
so you kind of gone your way in certain
areas that is absolutely true yeah okay
but I'm also not the type of person that
would buy a white rug with five kids and
you are
yeah it's worth it to me I just clean it
like just clean it and it's so beautiful
yep but hopefully it's a rug that cleans
easy I'm not gonna get like a super
right that's where we meet in the middle
yeah okay next do you always feel
strongly in love discover both of us and
how do you feel less like how do you
keep the spark alive and how do we keep
our relationship strong after so many
kids that's one that I got so many times
do I always feel strongly in them no no
no but then but that
that we see in our culture now maybe
maybe how about that what's the
definition of strongly in love like
being like the net infatuation stage
like in the beginning when you're like
first dating someone yeah because that's
a different infatuation and like a deep
unconditional way well yeah I mean I
still am strongly in love yes but it
doesn't necessarily feel like uh
it doesn't feel like what you picture in
the movies every day is that what it
makes sense yeah yeah like I think about
what you desire every day and I think
about
I just I think about you every day in a
way that I love you and I want to make
you happy and I want to be productive
and I want to take care of the kids and
I like every day I think if I'm grateful
for you and I love you and I pray for
you every day but
it's yeah I mean when you've been
married for 14 coming up on 14 years
it's just a different kind of love I
feel like it's gotten it's grown deeper
and it's uh just you connect in a deeper
way and it's less
um
us uh surfacy yeah I mean it's just less
um I know what you're saying it's just a
more like a stronger commitment like
it's a commitment that you make even if
you aren't as super hyped about the
person on a certain day or week or
whatever yeah the Ebbs and flows there's
ups and downs I think people ask that
question because there's such a strong
culture right now of like oh I fell out
of love with that person we're not we're
just not on the same page in life
anymore we're gonna go our separate ways
you know which is obviously common to
normal like before you've made a
committed relationship but that's even
common in a committed like a married
relationship
yeah well you have to be committed if
it's going to work if both people aren't
committed it's not going to work I mean
it's pretty clear because there's going
to be days where you don't like what the
other person did or is doing or you may
feel annoyed or something but ultimately
what's your what's our goal here what's
it what what did we commit to when we
got married and I'm that's something
that comes naturally for me like I feel
like it's easy for me once I make the
commitment to something it's easy for me
to stick with it that's just kind of my
personality it's not something I have to
like work out as much and I know it
doesn't come natural to everybody and I
think it kind of is natural to you too
yeah I mean that's why we've been
together since we're
yeah sometimes people ask if we ever
broke up before we got married and
because a lot of times that happens
someone might say oh we've been together
since high school but they may have
broken up three times we never broke up
in between there was like one time when
we almost broke up like a few months
after we got together but that was it
and I think people are in a place now
where
divorce and it's going their separate
ways is so common that they go okay well
how do you keep the spark alive how you
stay strongly love and not resent the
person over time because a lot of times
it's oh like we're just not on the same
page anymore and so I'm gonna go look
for love in another place but I wonder
if people don't realize that you're
never gonna find someone that is just
always butterflies forever you're never
going to find someone that is
infatuation that stuff that you feel at
the beginning of relationship you
there's nobody where it stays like that
for you know 50 years like you can still
have that strong deep love and
especially times in your life where
you're just like so into the person and
you're like oh I'm just like so into you
and love you so much and hopefully
that's something that you experience
like the entirety of the relationship
but
the butterflies thing that the the the
feeling of keeping the spark alive I
think there's a balance between
infatuation and a spark that like you're
just so committed and in love with that
person
no yeah I would agree and that's why
like you have to have especially when
you have kids you have to have dates you
have to go on trips you have to spend
quality time with your spouse because we
don't have that and you have less of
that time where you do feel that strong
you know butterfly feeling like if you
don't have if you never come together
and connect and have quality time just
the two of you then it it can you know
feel like it's fading especially when
you have kids I mean the kids take up so
much time it's like we have to connect
after they go to bed otherwise our
relationship's gonna suffer we have to
have date nights or else you know it's
going to be hard so it's something you
have to work at yeah uh and be
intentional about just like when we were
talking about taking care of yourself if
you want your marriage is a threat any
relationship this can be just even with
your a friend or a non-uh intimate
partner like if you if your
relationship's gonna grow like you have
to do quality time you have to have
quality conversations and meaningful
time with that person if that
relationship's going to grow
and the same thing obviously goes for a
marriage and you have to be you know
commitment is is the most important
thing if you're not committed then it's
going to be easy when the hard times
come
if you're like oh well you know I must
not love them anymore kind of thing but
there's also another factor I think
about being willing to grow and if only
because sometimes there's relations
where maybe one person is willing to
grow and they're like so down for okay
how can we evolve and be our best selves
for the other and for us for for ourself
even and then maybe someone else might
be feeling oh this this person isn't
willing to change or grow or care about
my feelings and that's when people get
in this really stuck place so it's
easiest to keep the spark alive when
both sides are willing to grow and care
about each other's feelings like that is
oh yeah right because
it there's been times maybe when you and
I are struggling for you know we've had
periods of our marriage that have
definitely been lowers lows we just are
not vibing and we are just not loving
our experiences together but we come out
of it when the uh when we both humble
ourselves and figure out how I need to
do better
how you need to do better instead of
pointing the finger it's like reflecting
Inward and being willing to grow yeah
it's two ways a relationship's not going
to work if one person's putting an
effort and the other person's not right
it just doesn't work it doesn't work
yeah but but I would urge someone to not
be quick to go to that place and assume
well this person I'm with is not willing
to grow so that's why we're we have to
partner separate ways because it takes
two to tango most of the time like
there's going to be exceptions to the
role of course like if someone's in an
abusive relationship or
um like extreme examples but for the
most part I would argue that it's more
often that you have to reflect in where
you can't just point the finger be like
oh well I'm willing to grow but they
aren't because really you might you're
probably doing something that is
triggering the other to act as their not
best self and yes that's something they
need to work on to not be so you know as
triggered but it's also something you
can work on to make it easier okay how
can I respond differently so that the
person receives what I'm feeling better
yeah I mean being unselfish and humble
is a must like you can't have a good
relationship without those two things
because there's certain things that ways
you receive love that I just don't
really feel like doing or that don't
come naturally and I
I have to do them if I don't do them
then you don't feel loved yeah and vice
versa yeah exactly so I mean if you you
have to humble yourself you have to be
unselfish that's what just think about
how you handle with your kids like if
you're selfish with your kids you're
gonna have a very good relationship with
them no of course not but you can't be
selfish with your spouse either or be
unwilling to give them what they need
because if you are then they're not
gonna they're gonna have a hard time
loving you back and you're going to have
a hard time receiving love the way that
you want to receive it because if you're
not given it's going to be harder for
them to get to not give back but that's
why you know if you're committed to
someone you know commitment is key like
I've committed to you so I'm gonna do
everything I can to make it work yeah
and there's certain things that I've
learned that we both learned from each
other over the years like okay Andrew
really doesn't like it if I'm gonna
bring up a controversial
um like something that's gonna cause a
conflict where we have a disagreement
right before bed okay duly noted don't
do that pick the times of the day that
your part you know your partner receives
um like maybe a conflict better where
you go okay this person would appreciate
if I'm gonna bring something up that
maybe might be a frustrating
conversation but it's important what's
the time of day that they this is just a
little mini example that they receive it
better or the love language thing you
were talking about for you words doesn't
come supernaturally but it's like my
number one favorite thing whereas for me
acts of service is kind of your is it
access service or Quality Time or like a
level yeah a little bit of both
um both are super strong and for me like
you know making sure there's no crumbs
on the floor and no sand in the car when
I get in the car is kind of like doesn't
come naturally to me but he really
appreciates when I take those extra
steps to wipe the sand off my feet
before I get in the car because that's
something that like I wouldn't mind as
much if the car had sand on the floor
but you do mind it so that those extra
things we have to constantly be evolving
ourselves instead of going oh well you
shouldn't care so much it's just staying
on the car or why do you need me to tell
you I love you like you know I love you
just the it that back and forth isn't
helpful and it makes me think of a
marriage class we took um with the basic
emotional needs which is kind of like
the love languages it's the 10 basic
emotional needs I think I've talked
about it before on Instagram years ago
but it's like the Love Languages but it
kind of goes a little bit more in depth
and there's like 10 basic emotional
needs and you rate one of the most top
five most important to you and then your
partner can see that be like oh wow I
didn't realize that was like your number
one most important thing and there's
this analogy of Your Love bank and how
in the beginning you're so excited about
each other and you're all you're adding
all the coins To Each Other's Love Bank
you each have your own love bank and
you're adding coins by doing all the
things because you're being your best
self you're putting your best foot
forward and then over time you you know
they love you so you kind of just relax
a little bit and it's easy to get to a
place where you're no longer adding
coins and you might even be taking coins
out through the things that make them
feel unloved so for me that would be
like negative words that if Andrew says
a negative word that might be taking a
left point out or for him that would be
if I don't do the dishes and I keep
leaving dishes in the sink like that
type of stuff is like taking a coin out
and over time that's how relationships
end up falling flat and like being
becoming no longer having that spark
alive because you don't feel in love
with that person anymore so it really
comes down to you each other ourselves
that was uh that marriage class we did
was
very very good for us because we had
done the The Love Languages book but
this took it just another step forward
for further and revealed some things and
it was just like you had you were doing
it with other people and they like
encouraged you to do it and it was just
nice having some accountability in it as
well uh and then understanding it's like
well now that I know this and I don't do
it then I'm like I'm being rude at this
point because like they told me what
they want and I'm not gonna do it yeah
then that's on me like that's just
that's selfishness that's your arrogance
or not humbling yourself so yeah you
know doing things like marriage classes
or reading books together or if you're
having troubles you go into therapy
whatever it is like those are the types
of things that you kind of have to do if
you're gonna have a you know
decades-long relationship yeah and over
time you start to realize like it could
even be little things that maybe your
partners asked you to stop doing or to
do that you just kind of put on the back
burn and go oh well that's his problem
that he cares so much but then this
class was like no you really do need to
care about those things because it goes
back to how you were when you first were
together you're putting your your best
foot forward and so you need to do that
that too the longer that you're together
and it that is I think what keeps the
sparkle at like knowing what the other
person desires and trying your best to
meet that to do those things to help
that person feel loved and care about
their feelings so a really tiny example
would be that I sneeze really loud and
we have this ongoing joke about how
Andrew hates how loud I sneeze and for
years I like didn't take it like
seriously because it was like that's
just the way I sneeze like come on
you're being way too critical and then
in the married class it was like what's
the number one thing that you can't stay
at like it was like what was the number
one thing that wasn't the number one it
was just one of them one of the most
important and it was like for you you
said that Ellen's knees is too loud I
was like what like this is the thing
you're gonna hang your hat on but then I
really understood oh like he really
doesn't like it it's annoying so then I
started being more conscious right
before I'm about to seize okay okay
Channel it make it smaller and I feel
like I'm doing a really good job now yes
you don't exaggerate your scenes anymore
and I love you even more now
but every time you sneeze you put a
little coin in my bank
even when you're far away you'll oh you
could tell it I'm trying
oh
okay so someone was asking for you to
share a little bit about behind the
scenes being a home birth dad your
experience five times what are your tips
to be a supportive partner and
um just what it was like for you to be
on the other end of the lens like to be
the other side not me you know because
people are saying me and my reaction how
I feel and yes you're part of that and
you're there but during the birth
experience or just in general the
pregnancy up to the birth birth but also
yeah well
I mean I when we first got married and
we were pregnant with Elvis
I was a little like worried about home
birth just because I didn't I didn't
really know anything about home birth
really that was more of it I just I was
like wait
that doesn't make any sense why wouldn't
you just go to a hospital it's safer
there uh and then we watch that video
business being born right The Business
of Being yeah the business of being born
and I was like oh oh this is what home
birth can look like oh I want to do that
yeah I didn't really like hospitals but
I just assumed that's the norm so then
once I did that I read a bunch of books
uh I read one of anime Gaskins books
even uh this was back when I was working
at a health food store and every lunch
break I would pick out they had a book
section and I was this was before
smartphones yes
I read way more books then and I I want
to start reading more but I read so many
books while I was working there every
lunch bag on every lunch break including
some home birth books and then I became
like a proponent like oh yeah this is
the best way like even though we even
hadn't had our kid yet uh so going into
it uh
I had to change my mind about it but
then I was fully supportive ultimately
it was where does Ellen want to have the
baby because it's I'm not having the
baby obviously it's my son or daughter
and I want them to be safe but I wanted
you to be in the place that you felt the
most comfortable in ultimately like if
we were gonna like if I wasn't sure a
little bit I was gonna defer to you on
that and so yeah we had a home birth and
I couldn't imagine it any other way now
oh my gosh no hearing people's stories
about Hospital bursts like some of them
obviously are great and they that's
where the mom feels comfortable but I'm
just grateful that that's something we
both wanted to do and that we got to
have and then we got to have five
smooth home births with no issues and
that went really really well and we had
amazing midwives and getting to have the
kids be there
and you know nothing compares to that
moment when you're meeting your baby and
having to be in your own home and not
like around people you don't know I know
that is my favorite part for sure being
in the like I'm in the comfort of my own
home with people that I know and want to
be as a sacred experience yeah totally
and you know the best thing probably not
like with our last couple bursts is just
watching the kids the other siblings
reaction because a lot of hospitals
don't allow the siblings to be in there
and you know think of like Elvis
witnessing four of his siblings births
and he is going to remember them all
like that's so cool so cool he's been
the more burst than like the average
adult yeah yeah most people probably
haven't seen birth unless they have kids
themselves I know I know do you have any
um suggestions or tips for a partner to
be supportive in the time maybe even in
the birth let's go specifically to the
birth
yeah well game plan with your your
partner and and uh plan kind of she's
probably should tell you the types of
things she wants maybe the lighting
where the other kids should be uh what
your roles are ask her what you wanna
what how she wants the house what towels
does she want you to use just plan
little things like that so when the time
comes and then have support you know
like I wouldn't suggest having a
unassisted home birth I know people do
that but having a doula or obviously a
midwife there is was something we always
had
and having you know I'm kind of the
director of like hey grab this do this
obviously the midwife's telling me
things to do as well but just do
whatever she wants
you know don't question a mom that is
pregnant and never question a mom that
is in labor yeah
yeah the first time especially it's been
so exciting like I think
it's happening and be like what do you
need like I'm like okay change the trash
go grab me some coconut water at
Mother's Market do I forget what else
but you did this whole list made chili
yeah you made sure for The Midwives you
like just got you and you're just so
good at that just like the task the on
time yeah I like knowing what to do I
didn't want to like be guessing like uh
what should I should I yeah sweep the
floors like I don't know like
like it was nice to be able to know what
to do and then feel needed but then also
don't take it personally
if
you're right not that you ever did this
but did I yeah like sometimes you didn't
like I'm pressing on you're like
pressing on your back no not right there
oh geez sorry
yeah like give me some space yeah and
just uh let you do your work yeah for
sure but then be supportive at the same
time yeah and just like asking what you
need so you were very physically there
for me I wanted your closeness like a
lot especially every Birth has been
different but as it as I've gotten more
and more labors that I've had they've
been quicker and just more you know
after the experiences of how changing my
mind and stuff like that and just your
support your steady support has been
amazing through all of it no matter what
my experience was and I think maybe
sometimes people ask that question
because they're just unsure what to do
so that's helpful to just tell them yeah
I mean before we had kids I I didn't
know what to do yeah yeah so a lot of
people asked what you do for work what
you do for a living and I think it's so
interesting that
um I mean it makes sense if you're not
like in our life you might not really
know what our our world looks like maybe
you can explain and elaborate a little
bit but it's helpful that you explained
in the beginning how when we you know
before we moved to Hawaii and especially
after we moved to Hawaii you had two
jobs working
60 hours a week until my job just
started to take off really naturally and
we're like okay there's something
something here I I should do more of
this because I was gaining an audience
really naturally without even trying on
Instagram I was just sharing my life and
we're like we should do something with
it so I started I started spending more
time creating and you started spending a
little bit less time working until we
could see that I was making an income on
it and slowly but surely you're you're
outside of the homework got lower and
lower but that doesn't mean you don't
work so I wanna I wanna share like a
typical Andrew day and what what you do
what do you do I feel semi-retired
but at the same time my days are very
full uh yeah so I
I don't work a regular job now you know
I quit what was that 2017 I think I
stopped working I was the manager at a
health food store that night job I had
uh I quit that and I then I was just
doing zipline to a guide for like a
couple days a week just for fun and to
get out of the house uh but then I found
that the more hours I was at home with
you and helping you with your business
it was more beneficial financially to do
that so I was like well I guess I'm
quitting my job and I remember you being
like really are you sure you sure yeah
yeah because that was part of it like do
you want to quit your job we don't want
to just do this just because it makes
more sense financially like do you want
to be at home because a lot of parents a
lot of times guys are men or women might
be like I don't want to be at home I
want to be at work so how how was that
decision for you mentally yeah it was
easy in the moment once I ran the
financial numbers yeah I'm pretty
Financial oriented I'm like okay here if
I spend you know I'm not making as much
doing this or making more doing this
okay we have enough save in case
something went wrong like no-brainer but
yeah in the beginning it was kind of
like wait what do I do now like going
from 60 hours a week to no hours a week
of working somewhere else but it did
gradual it didn't just go from 60 days
it was like but like just kind of okay I
don't have a job anymore where that I'm
going to it was
it was like what do I do with myself
there wasn't there was like periods of
time where it was like did I make the
right decision uh
but then I you know as the years have
passed I've just been more and more
grateful for it you know I get to uh
work in the garden I don't work in the
garden as much as I'd like to I'm doing
more homeschooling now but I get to
homeschool the kids uh I get to be with
them most of the day I get to coach
their sports teams yeah you coach all of
their sports teams and that takes up a
lot of time yeah I have the freedom to
do that and then I'm able to help you
where you need it with your filming or
with your customer service or your
emails and I'm able to have a little
part of helping you out and helping you
plan plan stuff
and be the financial person of the
business and doing the tax stuff and all
the stuff that you love to do
yeah a lot of people kind of think oh
it's I mean understandably so that it's
it's just Alan Fisher because that's
what Ellen Fisher podcast Ellen Fisher
Instagram Elementary YouTube like and I
am like the face of it and the Creator
but Andrew and I are a team he works
like just as much as me in our life
total work being all types of things not
just business oriented but of all the
tasks that we do we are constantly on
the go so I always chuckle and it's like
what does he do I'm like what does he
not do because you do everything like
you you help out with so much you are so
engaged and how lucky our kids get to be
to grow up with their dad in their life
throughout their whole day that is so
rare so rare these days a lot of times
it's rare even for both both mom and dad
let alone
let alone the dad you know and then on
top of it you answer all the emails and
you help me with Concepts and you're
very you have opinions on what I'm what
I'm gonna do too and I'll go to him for
opinions we brainstorm things together
you help me with filming like you said
earlier so like we're very much a team
and it's not like Oh Ellen works and
Andrew doesn't that's not at all what it
is so I think that's helpful to explain
yeah I think we explained it explained
it pretty well it's nice to have be a
part and be a team with you and it's not
you know I don't mind doing the behind
the scenes stuff that you don't really
want to do or you maybe don't have as
much knowledge or want to learn how to
do and I like doing Financial stuff and
the tax stuff doesn't you know just I've
always kind of been
someone that enjoyed enjoyed that anyway
so it's nice to have like a role and be
able to do that and uh and take that
burden off you yeah make so you can
focus more on the creative aspect of the
business because that's definitely my
favorite part and when I'm like like
love doing but actually sometimes a
couple times I've seen someone say like
why don't you just take a back seat now
and let Andrew do a project let him do
his passion project and what he likes to
do so what would you be your response to
that like do you have any passion
projects that you or just anything you
would like to be doing more of if you
had more time sure I would like to I
mean I don't think of it as like
necessarily having specific projects
other than maybe more to the Garden
that's probably my number one yeah thing
that I feel comfortable doing and that I
enjoy doing that brings me fulfillment
uh
just more free time would be nice yeah
that are like okay as time
kind of getting to this phase we're like
okay we got a few more years maybe four
more years and then we'll have more
freedom in our life you know freedom is
such a relative word because our life is
so free like we are yeah we we have such
a beautiful free life and we are of
course so grateful for it there's no
ungratefulness going there but just in
regards to more freedom of time to do
some other things like relax yeah
there's some hobbies that I'm probably
you know I'd like to get into kayaking
and canoeing and Hiking more but yeah
and as the kids get older you can
probably do more of those things with
them you know having a lot of young
children it's hard to do yeah a lot of
those types of activities but our kids
are getting older now and I know there's
a like there's gonna be a period of time
where I've been able to do more of those
and it doesn't necessarily bother me
yeah uh that I can't always you know
just run off and I'm gonna go kayaking
this morning and be gone for three hours
yeah yeah totally but that is that would
be something that I'd you know I would
like to get to one day yeah but passion
projects I just like love supporting you
and I and and making our home beautiful
and taking care of the kids and and
teaching them things and coaching them
you know that's one of my my biggest
passions is my kids yeah and you do such
a good job at that so that's actually
another question I want to ask you is
what three characters characteristics
would you like to instill in your
children
what would you what would you love for
them someone worded it really well
forget how they worded it I mean
kindness
no I want them to have integrity and do
what is right even if everybody else is
saying do something else I want them to
be free thinkers
and not just believe everything they say
uh what about anything we say anything
we say or anything they read and how to
analyze stuff they read and how to when
they hear something how to think for
themselves about it like that doesn't
make sense to me or how to how to be a
free thinker
um but ultimately I want them to be kind
compassionate
people that are full of integrity and uh
I don't know if it's like the top three
but those are some of the
characteristics I'd like them to see and
be eventually fathers and mothers that
raise wonderful children yeah I want
them to set them up I had great parents
uh and I'm so grateful for that so
parenting is something that kind of
comes naturally to me because I learned
from such great parents yeah and your
dad as well was at home a lot of the
time so that comes really naturally too
because he maybe you can talk a little
bit about that about how your adapted
yeah my dad had his own business and he
was sold insurance and he similar to me
in the beginning when I was younger he
would work nights doing his a lot of his
paperwork and stuff like that and he
would still make time for coaching our
teams and be home for a lot of dinners
and stuff and then uh when I was in my
teenage years he had to retire early
because of a medical condition so he's
but he's still even when he didn't feel
his best still
made coaching our teams a priority and
coming to all our games and just being
around the house and he never used it as
an excuse to not be a present father so
I know a lot of people maybe didn't have
that but that doesn't mean you can't be
a good parent but it's something you may
have to work at harder and it's not that
I don't have to work at being a good dad
but I'm just so grateful that a lot of
those things weren't instilled in me
from a young age and I hope to be able
to pass that down onto my kids so that
they can raise you know great great kids
as well yeah yeah so that's what your
your parents are amazing so how do we
handle this is back to the relationships
topic a little bit how do we handle
arguments to not ruin the whole mood of
the house
the whole movie like the kids yeah
don't talk about it yeah
just forget about it sleep it under the
road no I mean that's something that you
I naturally sometimes just want to avoid
it like oh whatever it's not that big of
a deal we'll just sweep it under the rug
but you don't let us do that well no but
you're there's a balance because you're
right you're right in that there are
certain things little things that are
like it's not worth it let it go and
just move out with the day that I had to
learn a lot from you at the beginning
because in the beginning I was very like
wait we had this little minor tip we
need to have an hour conversation about
it and then over time learning from you
no we actually don't need to do that and
there are many times where you can just
okay moment is over done
um but then you also I feel like have
learned from me to be like we can't do
that every time and if something becomes
a habit
that is like a continual habit for our
daily day we have to we have to find a
time to talk about it but it's best if
you're if you're gonna have a
conversation like that this is tread
mindfully of like the the mood of the
room of the house yeah I prefer not to
be in disagreements around the kids
you don't necessarily
mind as long as it stays respectful but
you'd like I mean I think it's okay to
see okay I think it's good that kids see
their parents disagree as long as they
resolve it well yeah we don't always do
that but
that should be a goal I think I just
didn't my parents rarely ever disagreed
in front of me as a kid
so I didn't really learn that aspect of
a relationship of how to have a
relationship it was like I'm sure they
have their disagreements like everybody
but they always handled them privately
and I never saw them so I didn't really
learn
how to handle disagreements in a
marriage and then marrying you you're
like well we gotta talk about this right
now you're like what I'm mad right now
yeah I don't want to talk about it right
now or this is dumb to me so let's just
forget about it where he's like well
this isn't Dumb to me so having to learn
so we've kind of both set boundaries
like if I'm feeling too upset
and I say I don't want to talk about it
I walk away like
I have to respect that I have to wait
until there's a time when we're alone or
in a a better place where he's in a mood
where he can sit and give me an Engaged
attention and that you're not distracted
or when you've calmed down or whatever
we have to respect each other's
boundaries yeah I need more time than
you do like when I'm upset I need a
longer period of time to cool off than
you do yeah you're ready to go right
away oh we disagreed I'm not ready to go
I'm like no I'm annoyed let's work it
out oh yeah I can ease very quickly not
be annoyed if we just work it out and
talk it out whereas for you you're like
give me some space to calm down and then
we'll talk but I I think the importance
of I think it's important for your kids
to see their parents disagree on
something in a healthy respectful way
because it shows them how to disagree
because like you said you didn't get to
see that and so when that came up it was
a little bit of a surprise for you like
how do I handle this I was never modeled
how to handle this because you and your
family don't really have many
disagreements
um let alone did you see it in front of
your parent likely your parents doing it
because obviously every every parents
like there are going to be disagreements
and so I feel like it's healthy to see
kids see their parents disagree so long
as it is resolved helpful healthfully
and we're staying respectful so there
are certain times when we find out or we
realize okay this is not going to a
healthy place we're starting to get too
upset where we're not using respect like
respectful language or tone and stuff so
that's when we go put a pin in it stop
like Andrew will say like we're done we
need to wait or I will even sometimes
and then that's when we go back to it
later so for us the the question of how
to handle arguments not ruining the
whole mood is like if we can stay
respectful and it's something small
enough we will continue that
conversation even if like the kids are
around and it's good for them to see
something resolved they see oh this is
how you you know apologize to each other
or or just listen to each other and
respect each other and so that's kind of
the balance if it starts to get too
heated we go pause put a depending and
we'll get to it later that's kind of the
yeah that's our goal that's our goal
it's not we're not perfect yeah our kids
have definitely seen unhealthy arguments
from us
um but hopefully there's been the mass
majority of time that's not what they're
seeing yeah yeah
um oh man there's so many good questions
we got a lot written down there I know
I'm not going to get to all of them how
does it feel in the first moment that
you find out your wife is pregnant
no this was one of the ones you asked me
last year we were going through
something that you might ask me yeah it
feels different with each one
the first one was like mind-blown
like just so surreal I remember that one
more than any of them I was standing in
a tiny little kitchen in that little
Studio we had or I guess there's a one
bedroom it was so attended like the roof
the roof was barely yeah seven foot
ceiling and you came out of this little
slider bathroom door and you told me
you're pregnant I was at the sink or
something I remember every detail really
I barely remember that and just being
like I don't remember exactly all the
emotions I had other than this just
sense of happiness and just joy and
shock and all that and then uh with each
one that
that faded a little bit it wasn't as
much of a like what like it wasn't as
much of a a shock but and even to the
point of number four and five or was
almost like a daunting yeah yeah Noble
because we planned everything in our
life but the last two children were
surprises and so it was a definitely a
different
a different emotion yeah in the
beginning like the first initial finding
out yeah it's filming myself with number
one and number five would have been a
very different yeah oh my gosh did I
ever share how the fifth one went uh uh
I feel like four I was in the most shock
yeah oh yes well no no four no five was
much more in shock for you four you guys
the fourth one Andrew knew I was
pregnant before I did it was so not on
my radar because I have a very
consistent cycle but for some reason I
was just so busy with work this is
before I got pregnant with my fourth I
was so busy with work that and I and I'm
never late so the only time I was on my
radar to be late is if I was planning to
get pregnant and so it wasn't on my
radar at all I'm at the computer I'm
like oh that's weird it's like day three
days past my cycle oh well and I keep
going and then the fifth day six day
come around I'm like that's so weird huh
interesting and then I keep going and
I'm just I just still not putting it
together and then I think it was the
11th
day after my cycle that I sit down on my
computer with my smoothie and the first
step I take I'm like and then I realize
because I always like my previous first
three first first pregnancies was like I
didn't really like green smoothies so I
sat like in the first trimester
especially so I sat down had that same
feeling I was like oh
I am pregnant and Andrew you walk in the
door after running errands and I'm like
Andrew I think I'm pregnant and you're
like I've been thinking that for days
you've been taking naps and random times
of the day what was that you said I
think you're saying yeah it was like 5
30 in a in the afternoon or evening I'm
making dinner and I'm like Ellen Ellen
like what are you doing back there
you're laying in bed like sleeping
taking a nap and I was like oh because I
never take naps but I didn't say
anything at the moment I was like if I
don't say anything then it might not be
real not that I didn't want to have
another one I just we hadn't planned it
so I was like wait a second we didn't
plan we planned our first three like
yeah yeah we were unsure we thought we
were probably done but we were like
maybe we'll have a fourth so that one
then when I took the test like sure
enough you know you had already been
mulling it over that I might have been
pregnant but the fifth one that was the
one that really knocked you out of your
boots because I didn't believe it you
didn't believe it and I knew it all of a
sudden because it was like the same
thing as last time over but a shorter
period of time we had just come home
we're on our way home from dinner at
someone's house and my friend had said
oh yeah I thought I was pregnant but I
took a test and I wasn't and then we're
driving home from the dinner I'm like oh
my gosh I'm three days late and I'm
never like I'm never late I'm always so
consistent and I was like Andrew I'm
pregnant and he's like no you're not I'm
like no I am I know I am I'm never late
I've been that the same exact number of
days for this many months and I'm three
days late now you're like no way because
at this point we thought we were for
sure done at four
and then we got home and I'm like Andrew
tomorrow morning when you go to the gym
go pick me up a pregnancy test you're
like no no you're not pregnant like yes
I am I know I am and you you really
didn't want to do it and I finally with
you and I like get me a pregnancy test
so then you brought it home
sure enough there's like two tests in
the package and then I'm like oh you
should look at it with me you never look
at it with me I always find out first
and then I tell you so we go to the
bathroom I take the test and then it
says nothing you know how it gives you
two lines if you're pregnant one line if
you're not like one line shows that the
test worked but he didn't know that
because he's never taken a test and
there's nothing on there and he goes see
look you're not pregnant I'm like no no
it's a faulty test it didn't work like
there's nothing for some reason the test
didn't work I have to take another one
so I'm gonna wait till I have to pee
again you can go run errands and he's
like no no see you're not pregnant and
you really didn't want to believe me he
went to run errands with the kids and
the kids were you know all in the car he
comes home with like all the groceries
and all that oh all the kids and
everything and I had already taken a
test and it was the next one and it was
positive
and I come outside and I'm like guys I
need to tell you something and then I
just see Andrew's shoulders
like you're like oh like I just see your
whole body like sink because you're just
so busy it's not that you wouldn't like
love another baby of course like over
the next weeks then you're like oh my
gosh I'm so excited and we get so of
course like tag me can you imagine a
world without Dagny now can't even
imagine like she is the sweetest angel
we are so lucky to have her and it feels
like everything is meant to be and our
family felt so complete huh after she
was born yeah I feel like yeah anyways
sorry I've been talking a lot but that
story is so hilarious to me because you
did not believe me and I just I still
don't even believe you when because then
I looked at the test and there was the
one line and then the other line was
like super faded I was like No but
there at all it means I'm pregnant
because
I've already gone people too so that's
why it's a smaller line and also I'm
only three days past the day and you
hadn't had like the previous pregnancies
it was like you had
I could notice something different about
you and these this one just completely
caught me off guard oh my gosh and Elvis
knew as soon as I was like I have to
tell you guys something else goes you're
pregnant I think because you might have
maybe he heard us talking about it he
knew I had gotten a test
because I had to go where did you go Dad
I had to go to the store what did you
need he always asked all these questions
I had to get a test from Mom what kind
of tests no yeah such a good story I
never want to forget it but I
accidentally deleted that camera footage
that stunk
good okay well to round it out I have a
couple little shorter questions okay and
then one more interesting thing we
should talk about so I guess it's not
that rounded out but are you hanging in
how are you doing I'm fine okay good
okay bucket list places to visit
uh New Zealand
yeah beautiful Iceland
yeah I want to go there too I've already
been to Alaska but I want to go there
again with the kids yeah with the kids
that would be fun those are my three
three top right now what about going
back to tahini I want to go back there
for where we went for a honeymoon no I
would go back there too we live in a
tropical place it's not as important to
me yeah but New Zealand's number one
yeah it's so beautiful and everything
I've seen but I've never been there yeah
and it was close for so close the last
few years and then we keep having babies
and it's like yeah what are we gonna go
there sometimes I imagine it's traveling
when the kids are older like Justin yes
but like all the kids and New Zealand's
not a super long flight from Hawaii it's
like 10 hours I think which is yeah
that's not bad not as bad as if you're
coming from
North America yeah yeah okay favorite
baseball player of all time
is it Sandy coat Max he's up there but I
didn't get to see him pitch
unfortunately uh Clayton Kershaw another
Lefty in the Dodgers oh yeah he's my
favorite that's your number one favorite
what was your favorite as a kid uh Tim
salmon oh that's right he had your
birthday right yep
and uh Mike Piazza I had quite a few
that I liked but yeah Tim salmon was my
favorite as a kid Clayton Kershaw is my
favorite as a man we were maybe gonna
name the
fiker shop it was a boy but we thought
kofax and Kershaw like it's just too
many baseball players and also the sound
is too much but if we if I was talking
to Elvis like if for some crazy reason
we ended up having like nine kids which
is just like mythical not gonna happen
but then we could do a kofax I mean a
Kershaw a Kershaw yeah but not not like
right after coming no we are officially
high five to that how's
it yeah I was a little worried about
being officially done but yeah here we
are and I feel the same I felt like a
moment of
was
like taken from me not my body is your
body
went and got upset me but like when you
told me it is finished you text me it is
finished and I
felt this like sinking feeling even
though I knew I don't want another one
and like we are so good at five five I
feel so complete
but I don't know I don't know why
anybody else listening if you've had let
me know if you've had that similar
that's all we've known for the last 11
years is having kids so it's like wait
no we're done and like a lot of people
have their you know one two three kids
like in a pretty short window I mean
obviously people spread out their kids
too but like you've been pregnant or
nursing for almost 11 years yeah and
I've been a dad to young kids for 11
years so it's like that's all we've
known so it's kind of like wait we're
not going to do that anymore I know like
obviously we can't do it forever but it
was just kind of a
kind of like a mental thing I had to
think through and process yeah I feel
good about it yeah like an end of an era
it just feels like I never even
considered what life would be like after
this phase of life and now now I'm
thinking about it and I'm pondering yeah
yeah we still got a little baby yes a
little six months but we have so much
life ahead of us it's so crazy about
okay last question it's a little bit
more engaging but I want to talk a
little bit about not putting people in
boxes because this is something that a
couple years ago it was a couple years
ago maybe three years ago there was like
this thing going around where people
were looking at the posts that you were
liking on Instagram and who you were who
you follow on Instagram and there was a
lot of conclu a lot of people jump into
conclusions a lot of posts and videos
even videos made about about this about
me or you well Me by D Me by secondary
but but use like because Andrew follows
these people on Instagram that means
that Ellen is a that says this like a
right wing all these things anti this
Pro this whatever so maybe you could
share a little about your thoughts on
like not we talk a lot about this about
not putting people in boxes and
understanding
listening from all different
perspectives because the funniest part
about that to me was that people would
say oh Andrew follows Trump and he
follows I don't know a couple other
right people politically but then they
also didn't look that like you also
follow Joe Biden and you also follow
like who are the other ones you're so
much more into politics than I am but
whoever's the president oh Bernie
Sanders Bernie Sanders you felt you
followed like all the different all the
different politically things Dan
Crenshaw and all this stuff but people
saw that you followed a couple different
people that they really don't like and
they said it must you must be this this
this this
what are your thoughts yeah I don't
really care what other people think
about me to be honest yeah you are very
I think it's silly when you that people
would make such big assumptions based on
following someone on Twitter or
Instagram or Facebook or whatever it is
because I just I like
I like having disagreements with people
like I don't mind having political
discourse or having different opinions
on things that doesn't trigger me or
some people for whatever reason uh it's
more like how could someone think
something else than me like they must be
this type of person and that's just not
me so it's easy for me to follow
different people on social media that I
agree with and disagree with and it
doesn't it's not not triggering for me
to see someone post something that I
disagree with I'm like oh that's
interesting like it's not like it ruins
my day to see someone even if I think
it's like something that could be
possibly harmful like I understand that
people come from all different ways of
life and had so many different
upbringings that we kind of form our
opinions about things
uh politically or just what our
priorities are in life based off you
know a lot of what you know our
childhood and things that may have may
or may not have happened to us or our
parents or the religion we grew up in
and to understand that people get to a
certain point because of the experiences
they had it helps you understand
understand them a little bit better and
uh when you put people in boxes and just
say oh this person voted for this person
or follows this person it kind of takes
away their humanity and it kind of just
like it's like that's just not the kind
of it's not going to be very fruitful
for our country or for for people in
general if that we just treat people
like that uh but thankfully for me it
doesn't bother me when when people make
statements like that about me uh you
know a lot of the things that I'm
passionate about you know obviously I'm
a Christian and I'm passionate about
that and a lot of that is because of my
upbringing my parents were strong
Christians and I got to see that modeled
uh and I grew up in a church setting and
for some people that grew up in that
they may now be turned off to
Christianity as a result but I had a
good example of a Christian family and
Christian parents so that was a positive
example for me and it made me want to
seek after it on my own as I got older
but understanding that people that are
anti-christian or not Christian they got
to their reason they got to their way of
thinking because of maybe something that
happened in their life or didn't happen
in their life and understanding that
that's okay it's okay if someone doesn't
believe in the same thing as me or
politically the same thing like I have
certain values certain things that are
very important to me uh
that I'm passionate about because of
what I want what's best for my kids or I
was exposed to something and or was not
exposed to something
um I found that I don't have the exact
survey but there was a survey that
someone had shared about about uh
political affiliation and then their
thoughts on coven and people were asked
how serious uh they thought kovid was or
how what the death rate was or how many
people get Hospitality percent chance to
be hospitalized and people that thought
the facts were one way like say you
thought that coven was 50 of people that
got it were hospitalized and 20 people
died those people tended to be more
fearful of coven rightfully so and were
more likely to be concerned about what
other health choices people were making
with vaccines and mass whereas people
that felt like covid was not as serious
were less likely to to want to wear
masks or be worried about someone else
getting a vaccine and understanding like
you're going to have your opinions based
off what you believe is true and
sometimes our We Believe what's true
just because of our opinions and
sometimes we believe it because of fact
I tend to be more fact oriented and I'm
not as empathetic and I don't have as
I'm not more feeling feeling based so I
make my decisions more they're more cut
and dry what do the facts say but I
realize that's not everybody and
understanding that that's okay that
people have different opinions than me
and I'm ever going to put someone down
because they disagree with me because
ultimately most people just believe what
they believe because they think that's
what's best for them or their families
or for others we just maybe disagree on
how to get there and if you can
understand that most people are aren't
out to get you like someone that's on
the left or the right and you think the
other way they're not they're not doing
these things because they want to
destroy the world or destroy your family
or attack you personally or a group of
people personally they just have a
different path on making things better
and uh yeah it's unfortunate that
there's videos made
was the one I've never seen the one
where you had like a trump hat on I
thought that was hilarious superimposed
and then people actually thought it was
a real picture someone yeah so there's a
picture of me pregnant that I had posted
but then someone superimposed a trump
hat on top of my head like a fake
picture and someone had put that up in a
thumbnail of a video and then somebody
later he will later commenting yes
pictures later surfaced of Ellen wearing
a trump hat like those aren't even real
pictures that's a funny place I know and
I the funny thing is if I look back at
my voting record I think I voted for
four different political parties I've
never voted for the same political party
and back-to-back election presidential
elections oh my gosh you're right yeah
so I find it funny when people want to
put me in a box or assume something I'm
just kind of laughing off because yeah
that's not who I am and it doesn't
trigger me because I know that's not who
I that's not who I am yeah so you're
super confident yeah I'm confident and I
know the truth and I know what I believe
and someone on social media can't
possibly know that unless we have a
conversation and they get to know me
well yeah so that's why when somebody
sees a picture like oh Andrew liked this
picture or liked this post and this is a
horrible post it's anti this or that
instead of like jumping to conclusions
that must mean that Andrew is a bigot or
a blah blah instead like it would be so
much more engaging and fruitful to
figure out like why would somebody maybe
agree with that post or either go to him
directly or go like look at the other
side there are so many people that only
want to look at one side of the aisle of
anything this isn't just politically but
anything anything of hot debate that's
definitely there's so many topics of hot
debate that aren't just political and
listen truly listen to both sides
because if you think oh I can't even
listen to it that's not admirable to say
that I can't possibly understand why
anybody would think the other way it
because it just shows that you haven't
actually given it much time much effort
to really hear what the other side is so
how do you even know if you're on the
side of quote-unquote truth if you
haven't even given equal attention and
time to listening to both sides yeah you
should be able to argue the other way
that's what I try to I try to think okay
how could I argue this if I'm pro-life
how could I argue against pro-life or if
I'm
but pro-choice how could I argue against
pro-choice like once you are able to do
that it helps you to understand the
other side like I said earlier like most
people are just doing what they think is
right or morally acceptable or what they
think is going to be the most beneficial
to society and acknowledging like that
they're not coming from a place of evil
or wanting to harm and they're coming
from a place of Love most people
obviously there's people that aren't
that's not their goal but just the life
experience thing is such a big factor
like I'm pro-life like I'm not afraid to
say that but the reason I'm I'm that way
is there's so many life experiences that
I've had that I can't be other it's hard
for me to imagine not being that but I
can still understand why someone is on
the other why on the other side and you
know I'm a father I witnessed All My
Children be born I can't imagine doing
anything other than protecting my
children when I was in college I'd had a
biology class
we went to a hospital and there was a
five gallon bucket of fetuses that had
passed away and I don't know if they
were aborted or if they were and just
miscarriages went up there from 12 weeks
to 24 weeks and they weren't treated as
human they you know we weren't allowed
to see the the morgue or the adult
bodies were even though this was a
biology class but we were allowed to see
the fetuses because they didn't classify
them as human I guess
and they brought in this five gallon
bucket of about 20 of them and we were
able to pick them and hold them and look
at them and I was like these are humans
they're small but they're humans and
that formed my my belief so strongly
right there it was official yeah that I
was pro-life and I wasn't going to
change yeah because that's my experience
but if you've never lived that
experience and you've maybe seen the
opposite of someone being raped and
Pregnant and then seeing the horror of
having to go through that like I've
never had that experience so it's not
it's easy it's not easy for me to see
where they're coming from but I can
still like oh that would be hard even
though I haven't lived that experience
uh and just understanding that we all
get to our we all get to where we the
things we believe for a reason and for
the most part it's because we just want
what's best for others and what's best
for Society at least that's for me yeah
I agree with you I think that most
people are have pure intentions and so
to we should assume a pure intention for
all sides of the aisle of any topic that
you're passionate about that helps you
to go into the conversation better to
just try to understand the way someone
thinks as opposed to think jumping to
conclusions that someone who disagrees
with me must be a this this or this like
labeling because there's a reason why
someone thinks that way and it's
thoughtful and I encourage you to just
you know try to open you know our hearts
I encourage all of us to open our hearts
to try to listen to each other yeah
thanks for sharing all that sure this is
something that we Andrew and I we could
probably do an entire episode on
something like this part but I
definitely want to touch it towards the
end yeah that's great yeah enjoyed the
conversation I like talking about all
different types of things but obviously
on my certain topics that I'm more
passionate about for various reasons and
yeah for sure we're gonna we're gonna
have to get you on as a regular let me
know if you think Andrew should be on as
a regular
all right we're gonna end it here back
to the kids at the main house make some
lunch and it's gonna be a stormy day so
probably do a movie night and Andrew
making a delicious dinner what are you
gonna make tonight
oh we already did most of our fun
dinners that we watch movies for with
Hannah and Eric yeah so we'll let them
decide tonight yeah maybe some lentils
or something all right thanks everyone
for being here and thank you so much
Andrew for sharing all that you did I
love you I love you too bye
[Music]
another